hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doki doki literature
club alright we're picking up where we
left off
who should I show my poem to well gotta
go with Monica Monica hey Micah hey can
warp how's the writing going alright I
guess I'll take that as long as it's not
gonna be bad I'm happy that you're
applying yourself maybe soon you come up
with a masterpiece I wouldn't count on
that I am pretty skilled but more poet
you never know
want to share what you wrote today sure
here you go get my poem to Monica all
right I like it more really it's a lot
cuter than I expected ha ha oh jeez no
no no it kind of makes me think of
something Natsuki would write and she's
a good writer too so take that as a
compliment yep by any chance have you
read by anything by shel silverstein
yeah where the sidewalk ends maybe a
long time ago leaves famous for telling
all kinds of stories in just a few
simple words his poems can be funny
endearing or even sad and sometimes
they're only a few lines long they might
even make you feel like they've written
their be written for kids but if you
think about them they can express views
of the world that would apply to anybody
I see so you're saying that Natsuki is
kind of like that sorta maybe she's not
an expert but you probably won't find
much filler in her poems they might be
easy to write but they're super
challenging to get the meaning through
so I can see why it would be your kind
of poem to explore but anyway you want
to read my poem right I like the way
this one turned out so I hope you do too
all right let's take a look sue save me
the colors they won't stop bright
beautiful colors expanding piercing red
green blue an endless cacophony of
meaning noise the noise it won't stop
violent grading waveform squeaking
screeching piercing sine cosine tangent
like playing a chalkboard on a turntable
like playing a vinyl on a pizza crust an
endless poem of meaningless
load me load load me load me
[Music]
load beat load me load load you low
weight load what huh it's even more
abstract than your last one huh
ha ha ha ha I guess it's just the way I
write huh I'm sorry if you don't like it
no I never said that
it's this kind of thing I've never
really seen before I guess I kind of
like playing with my space on paper
choosing where and how you to space your
words can totally change the mood of a
poem it's almost like magic the way I
wrote the lines really short makes it
feel like they're trying to speak over
the noise I see it's still hard for me
to tell what it's about though sometimes
asking what a poem is about isn't the
right question a poem can be as abstract
as a physical expression of a feeling or
a conversation with the reader so
putting it in that way not every poem is
about something anyway here's Monica's
writing tip of the day sometimes you'll
find yourself facing a difficult
decision when that happens don't forget
to save your game you never know what
you might change your mind when
something unexpected may happen
it is this tip even about writing ok
what am I even talking about ha ha
that's my advice for the day thanks for
listening all right
[Music]
okay all right well I visited the URI
last zoo URI first you want my cutie
poem there it is let's see what you've
written for the day mmm that's pretty
good more were you influenced by seeing
everyone's writing sales yesterday I
guess you could say that I was also a
bit surprised by how differently
everyone writes so I respect you for
trying new things you don't need to be
afraid to be a little more daring
metaphors can go a long way don't feel
like you need to work your brain like
turning a bunch of gears try letting
your mind wander through your feelings
and write down the things you see in
here that's one way to truly enable your
reader to see into your mind it's a very
intimate exercise I see okay that's
certainly interesting technique thanks
for sharing I have um well an example of
that if you'd like to read it of course
I would that's what I like I like that
was it the poem you wrote for today URI
nods and timidly hands me your poem ah
velder Hakuna it happened in the dead of
night while I was slicing bread for a
guilty snack my attention was caught by
the scattering of a raccoon outside my
window that was I believe the first time
I noticed my strange tendencies as a an
ordinary human I gave the raccoon a
piece of bread my subconscious well
aware of the consequences well aware
that a raccoon that is fed will always
come back for more the enticing beauty
of my cutting knife was the symptom the
bread my hungry curiosity the raccoon an
urge the moon increments its phase and
reflects that much more light of my
cutting knife the very same light that
glistens in the eyes my raccoon friend I
sliced the bread fresh and soft
the raccoon becomes
excited well perhaps I'm merely
projecting my emotions onto the newly
satisfied animal the raccoon has taken
to following me you could say that we've
gotten quite used to each other
the raccoon becomes hungry more and more
frequently so my Brett is always handy
every time I brandish my cutting knife
the raccoon shows me its excitement a
rush of blood
classic Pavlovian conditioning I slice
the bread and I feed myself again all
right it's more of a novel than a poem
it's a story was a little more daring
with this one than yesterday's I can see
that you can see that it's a lot more
metaphorical not really I don't know if
it's my fault but I can't imagine what
this poem is about that's right it's a
bit closer to my preferred writing style
using the poem as a canvas to express
vivid imagery and conveying emotions
through them yeah if you I take it at
face value then I can't even figure out
what it's supposed to mean well I think
it's something that different people can
relate to in their own way I wanted to
express the way it feels for me to
indulge in my more unusual hobbies it's
those sort of things that I'm usually
forced to keep to myself you know
feeding raccoons and such so I sometimes
enjoy writing about them why do you keep
them to yourself be be aku as they're
embarrassing and people would make fun
of me don't you have anything like that
more well yeah yes I do I feel like
everyone is a little something like that
the best we can do is respect each other
in our individuality
even if it's difficult sometimes and
some things make us uncomfortable after
all if I haven't learned to embrace my
own weirdness I would probably hate a
myself I might be ranting a little bit
now but I'm glad you're still a good
listener oh you're welcome
who should I show my bum do I don't even
know what the hell just happened there
all right how about say are you sorry
sir and Cherie oh I like this one more
it has some nice feeling in it and
does it mean it's better than
yesterday's I think whatever I like I'm
both
yeah that's not very helpful you know
well I'm not very good at figuring out
if poems are good or bad but that's just
why I go by mama Hart if it makes me
feel things then it must be a good poem
I'm not sure that's exactly how it works
then again more guests conveying
feelings is a pretty important part of
this whole thing
yeah maybe honestly morp don't even know
what kind of writing you like in the
first place yeah me neither
oh why don't you at least try to give it
some thought oh you want to write
something for me that's so sweet
Yeah right but you're always thinking
about other people you need to think
about yourself once in a while if you
don't you might end up getting hurt at
some point that's weird
I don't really know what you mean by
that but I'll try to keep it in mind
well whatever anyway let's see hmm I
guess I like happy poems right sometimes
they're like sad poems do something a
little bit of both happy and sad there's
a word for that right melancholy I think
is the word you're looking for
enter sweet that's also a word
melancholy might not be the right word
yeah I like things that are happy and
things that are sad happy and sad I
can't see you liking something that said
C or E well I like happy the most but
sometimes when you have a little rain
cloud in your head a sad poem can give a
rain cloud the little hug and make a
nice happy rainbow you are disgustingly
happy yeah say re that's unexpectedly
poetic no it is maybe I'm getting better
in my feelings after all thanks more I
should get to write that down then you
can read my bum now okay all right here
we go
all right bottles I pop off my scalp
like the lid of a cookie jar it's the
secret place where I keep all my dreams
little balls of sunshine all rubbing
together like I'll bundle kittens I
reach inside with my thumb and
forefinger and pluck one out
boink it's warm and tingly but there's
no time to waste I put it in a bottle to
keep it safe and I put the bottle on the
shelf with all the other bottles happy
thoughts happy thoughts happy thoughts
in a bottle all in a row my collection
makes me lots of friends each bottle a
star like to make amends sometimes my
friends feel a certain way down comes a
bottle to save the day night after night
more dreams friend
and more bottles deeper and deeper more
fingers go like exploring a dark cave
discovering the secret hiding in the
nooks and crannies digging and digging
scraping and scraping I blow dust off my
bottle caps it doesn't feel like time
elapsed my empty shelf could use some
more my friends look through my locked
front door
finally all done I open up and in come
my friends and they come in such a hurry
do they want my bottles that much I
frankly pull them from the Shelf one
after another holding them out to each
and every friend each and every bottle
but every time I let one go it shatters
against the tile between my feet happy
thoughts happy thoughts happy thoughts
in shards all over the floor there was
supposed to be for my friends my friends
who aren't smiling they're all shouting
pleading something but all I hear is
echo echo echo echo echo inside my head
Wow okay Wow holy crap holy crap yeah
holy crap indeed holy crap sorry did you
really write this of course I did didn't
I tell you yesterday I was gonna write
the best poem ever yeah but I mean I
didn't expect something like this coming
from you
Monica taught me a whole lot and I've
been really in touch with my feelings
recently I see that it's almost kind of
creepy creepy well not exactly
maybe because I'm so used to be you
being so cheerful I'll never mind think
of to heart about this huh something
goes wrong here the point is it came out
good so you should be proud of it well
thanks I feel like feel like I was meant
to express myself this way it even helps
me understand my own feelings a little
bit better writing is like magic you've
gotten pretty passionate about this huh
I hope you keep it up yeah writing is
the best I'm gonna keep writing until I
die ah don't get ahead of yourself
[Music]
Sarah's always had a habit of giving
obsessed with something before dropping
it no more than a week later yeah wonder
if this is one of those times but seeing
the passion and her eyes makes it hard
for me to be pessimistic okay all right
Natsuki
Natsuki time here we go mizuki hey how's
it going
she keeps glancing at me been back at
the poem by now she must have read it
more than once are you supposed to be
bad at this is that a compliment no I
mean you know Natsuki struggles to find
the word she wants I just expected a lot
less after why'd you show me yesterday
that's all well I guess I just got lucky
with this one huh yeah exactly
you just got lucky you know don't get
used to it you won't always manage to
write poems is cute I mean I mean well
written no oh that's that's how it is my
poems cute no why are you smiling it's
all I can look you things that's if he
shoves my poem back towards me huh
reading again I decided is now so great
after all it's too cute and okey-dokey
it would only impress you know girls who
like that sort of thing
for some reason that suki is incredibly
easy to see through well anyway you're
gonna read mine now right judging by
your taste you'll probably like it a lot
you'll probably learn something too
don't forget who the real pro is maybe
like spiders you know what I heard about
Amy Amy likes spiders icky wiggly hairy
ugly spiders that's why I'm not friends
with her amy has a cute singing voice I
heard her singing my favorite love song
every time she sang the chorus my heart
would pound to the rhythm of the words
but she likes spiders that's why I'm not
friends with her one time I hurt my leg
really badly
Amy helped me up and took me to the
nurse I tried not to let her touch me
she likes spiders so her hands are
probably gross that's why I'm not
friends with her amy has a lot of
friends I always see her talking to
people
she probably talks about spiders
whenever friends start to like spiders
too that's why I'm not friends with her
it doesn't matter if she has other
hobbies it doesn't matter if she keeps
it private it doesn't matter if it
doesn't hurt anyone it's gross she's
gross the bet of the world is better off
without spider lovers and I'm gonna tell
everyone is this a poem about judging
someone for one thing no matter how good
they are if you let one thing ruin that
about them it's it's a bad way to judge
someone this is a really good poem is
this a really good one I like this I
really like that judging someone by one
characteristic flaw that you don't like
about them personally no matter how good
it is huh that's a really good poem and
speaks well that's great I leave that
one not bad that's really good quite a
bit longer yes it is was way too short I
was just warming up hope you didn't
think that was the best I could do
no of course not anyway the message is
pretty straight for him it is Boehm I
doubt I have to explain it sometimes you
can explain complicated issues with much
simpler animal analogies and it helps
people realize how stupid they're being
like anyone who would agree with the
subject of this poem is an ignorant jerk
do you know what people are like that do
you know people like that
of course it's about everyone how
everyone thinks might
that doesn't matter it can be about
anything I wrote it to be easy to relate
to everyone has some kind of weird hobby
or a guilty pleasure something that
you're afraid if people find out they
make fun of you or think less of you but
that just makes people stupid
who cares what someone else likes as
long as they're not hurting anyone into
makes them happy I think people really
need to learn to respect others for
liking weird things huh
that's funny Yuri wrote about something
similar today uh-huh did you say Yuri
yeah she said her poem was about an
unusual hobby of hers I didn't really
get it but she says something similar to
you that people shouldn't make each
other feel insecure about this things
really well I mean Yuri's pretty weird
so I wouldn't doubt that she has some
weird hobbies not that there's anything
wrong with that
it's not like the judge or anything no
suit he has trouble finding words I
guess I should try not to be so mean to
or she feels insecure about a weird
babies and stuff I mean I always hate
people who make me feel insecure and
Yuri made me feel insecure yesterday but
the way you put it it sounds like she's
learned her lesson oh I would say so
even if a writing style is really
different I'm sure she'll appreciate the
message in your poem that's what I do
best after all I don't like writing
unless it's a good message to take away
from it like conveying emotions is
important but I want to make people
think don't just feel remember that I'm
gonna write a good one for tomorrow too
so look forward to it
get back your cards don't make me bring
out the billy club where's Mack he
represented your cute heads bash it
right in go back me threatening I'm
something extra plant something extra
planned today so if everyone could come
sit in the front of the room is this
about the festival well sort of
oh do we really have to do something for
the festival it's not like we can put
together anything good in just a few
days well just end up embarrassing
ourselves instead of getting any new
members that's a concern of mine as well
I don't really do well with last-minute
preparations don't worry about so much
we're gonna keep it simple okay we won't
need much more than a few decorations
see Ori has been working on posters and
I've designed some pamphlets he can give
out during the event okay that's great
no but that doesn't tell us what we're
actually gonna be doing for the event oh
sorry I thought you heard about it
already we're gonna be performing
morning but uh Monica yeah we're gonna
be having a poetry performance each of
us are gonna choose a poem to recite
during the event but the cool part is
we're also gonna let anyone else come up
and recite poems to series putting it
out on all the posters in case anybody
wants to prepare of ahead of time Sarah
who's been coloring a poster holds it up
for us to see are you kidding me Monica
you didn't you didn't know Reese are
putting those posters up did you yeah
well I did do you really think it's that
bad of an idea well no it's not bad but
I didn't sign up for this you know
there's no way I'm gonna be performing
in front of a group of people like that
I agree with Natsuki I could never in my
life do something like that
imagining it URI shakes her head in fear
guys no Sayuri I understand where
they're coming from
remember that netsuke and URI never
shared their poem with anyone until it
just a couple days ago it's a lot to ask
for them to recite their poems out loud
to a whole room through people I guess I
kind of overlooked that so I'm sorry but
I still think we should give it our best
we're the only ones responsible for the
fate of this club if we start the event
and each put on a good performance then
it will inspire others to do the same
and the more people who perform the
better we'll be able to show everyone
that literature is all about yeah it's
all about expressing your feelings being
in a bit with yourself
finding new horizons and having fun
that's right and it's those reasons that
we're all in this Club today
don't worry don't you want to share that
with others to inspire them to find the
same feelings that brought you here in
the first place I know you do I know we
all do and if it does that's all it
takes standing for a room for two
minutes about reciting a poem that I
know you can do it okay
now Sookie and URI remain silent Sayuri
looks worried I guess that leaves me
with no choice I agree I don't think
it's too much to ask I think that say
Ori and Monika have been really trying
to get hard to get new members the least
we can do is help them out a little bit
well maybe but it looks like Natsuki
doesn't have any arguments left oh okay
fine all right I guess I'll just have to
get over it it's all right
whew thanks netsuke what about you URI
huh Gary dejectedly glances around at
everyone else's expected faces sigh I
guess I don't really have a choice
oh that's everyone you're the best Yuri
this club is seriously gonna be the
death of me oh gosh wait
foreshadowing I port Chatham you'll be
fine Yuri but anyway let's move on to
the main event I want you to choose a
poem of yours we're gonna be practicing
reciting them in front of each other
Monica well if you can't recite your
poem in for the club how do you expect
to do it in front of strangers oh no
don't worry
I'll start off to help everyone feel a
little more comfortable can I go next
of course now let's see Monica flips
through her notebook to a specific poem
she has in mind for herself gonna say
before this okay that stands behind the
podium the title of this poem is the way
they fly ahem Monica begins reciting her
poem her clear confident voice fills the
room more than that her inflection is
pristine she knows exactly how to apply
emotion behind each line she recites
bringing the words to life is this
something she's done before or is she
simply a natural a glance around me
everyone has their eyes on Monica say or
he looks amazed URI has an intense
expression on her face that I don't
understand finally Monica finishes a
recitation the four of us applaud Monica
takes a breath and smiles that was Oh
Monica ah thank you very much I was just
hoping to set a good example are you
ready to go next say Orie oh I'll go
next
I will Oh URIs fired up all of a sudden
your clutches a sheet of paper between
your hands stands up keeping her head
down she walks quickly over to the
podium this poem is called you're
anxious advances at each of us you can
do it URI it's called after image of a
crimson eye URIs voice shakes as he
starts reading the poem just a moment
ago she practically refused to do this
why is she so suddenly putting in so
much effort as URI gets past the first
couple lines her voice changes it gets
deeper then room dark the lights all go
out everyone care - a cold breeze
rushing through the window right there
quivering words transform into the sharp
syllables of a fierce and confident
woman
the poem is full of twists and turns and
it's structure that she enunciates with
perfect timing this must be a rare
glimpse into the whirling fire Yuri
keeps concealed inside her head suddenly
she's finished
everyone is stunned Yuri snaps back into
reality hoop circles gravity mom
spaghetti starts spilling out of her
pockets and glances around her eye it's
up to me to save the situation on the
first to start applauding all right
there we go sound that we didn't want to
applaud Ferb but we're caught off guard
says she must have we must have
forgotten as we applaud your upholds a
poem to her chest and rushes back into
her seat Yuri
that was really good don't you dare
upstage me ever again
I will kill you thank you for sharing
looks like Yuri is down for the count
okay I guess I'm next then Sara hops out
of her chair and truly walks to the
podium
this one's called my meadow ah ah ha ha
sorry I giggle say Orry it's a lot
harder than I thought how did you guys
do it so easily ah trying to think of it
like you're reciting to other people
imagine you're reciting it to yourself
like in front of a mirror or in your own
head it's your poem after all so it'll
come out best that way I see I see okay
then
Sara begins her poem somehow it feels
like your soft voice was made as a
perfect match the poem is an aimlessly
cheery Lexi aureus it's serene and
bittersweet if I were to read this on
paper I probably wouldn't think too much
of it but hearing it come from Sayuri's
voice almost gives it a whole new
meaning
maybe this is what seorae meant when she
said she likes my poems it's like I get
to reach more deeply into someone I
thought I knew through and through
saiary finishes if we applaud I dared
him
good job say Ori huh even more flecked
it I guess that's a good sign if more
plike what does that even mean
came out it's nicely sorry the
atmosphere of the poem fits you really
nicely but it might be that other poems
wouldn't work quite as well with that
kind of delivery yeah I don't really
understand in other words I've seen
poems of years where that sort of gentle
delivery wouldn't work as well they
might need a little more force behind
them depending on what you're reading oh
I know what you mean that's well I've
been practicing that kind of thing it's
just a bear thing to do in forever
hey then next time I'm gonna make you
pick a poem that challenges you a little
more we don't have much time before the
festival you know okay now who's next
Natsuki no don't make me go before morp
all I can compare to you guys anyway
might as well let more blow or
everyone's standards a little blooper
have to do it Natsuki oh come on now
it's fine it's fine
I might as well get it over with but
it's not like I have much of a selection
of what to read I'll go with what I
wrote for today I stand up and step in
front of the pro podium everyone has
their eyes on me make you feel awkward
oh hello well I thank you for all
standing in order of tallest to shortest
and also biggest boobs to smallest boob
I appreciate that that's really welcome
I guess
okay anyway I recite my poem since I'm
not exactly confident in my own writing
it's hard to put energy into it despite
that once I finish I receive applause
anyway I'll applaud myself don't worry
more Paz more back so I'm not really as
good as everyone else don't worry about
so much I think it's less about your
abilities more about your lack of
confidence in your writing that's
something that will improve over time
though yeah maybe
all right then that just leaves you
Natsuki yeah yeah okay I'm going
Natsuki begrudgingly gets out of her
seat and makes her way to the podium the
poem is called it's called why are you
all looking at me because you're
presenting me anyway the pods called
job that's it he takes a breath once he
starts reciting the poem or sour
attitude disappears a little while she's
still a little unenthused her poem has a
rhythm and rhyme to it it's not Sookie's
trademark style and it worked
surprisingly well when spoken aloud the
words feel like they bounce up and down
as if giving life to the poem now Sookie
finishes and everyone applauds she
Huff's back to her seat that wasn't so
bad was it easy for you to say you
better not make me do that again
oh well do you at least feel prepared
enough to recite a poem in front of
other people I mean doing it in front of
other people will be way easier I can
put on whatever face I want for other
people but when it's just my friends
it's just that's a surprise in the
Sookie I think it would be the other way
around for me well that's just how it is
so I guess in that case you won't have
much to worry about it for the festival
that's it I want to thank you everyone
for coming through it might be hard but
I
that you all have an idea of what it's
like now make sure you pick up all them
and get enough practice before the
festival okay I'll be making pamphlets
so let me know at the time what you'll
be reciting geez
you should probably find some other way
poem to recite instead that's fine too
it doesn't have to be your own
I'm already pleasantly surprised that
you're all putting in the effort for the
club look it makes me really happy and
you know what that means I guess uh yeah
no problem okay everyone I think that's
about it for today I know the festival
is coming up but let's try to write
poems for tomorrow as well okay it's
been working out really nicely so far so
I'd like to continue with that that's
for the festival we'll finish planning
tomorrow and then we'll have the weekend
to prepare Monday is the big day I can't
way I can do this I could do this
all right great I stand up there's no
way I'll be able to find the same
enthusiasm as C or E and Monica but I'll
do my best to get through it if it's for
the sake of the club and I'm impressing
Monica but I'll have to do my best
ready to go say re yep yeah biruni look
at you two always going home together
like that
it's kind of adorable isn't it oh geez
guys don't make it such a big deal out
of it must be a little nice so well ah
how am I supposed to respond to that
it's okay morp you don't have to say it
whatever let's go already
all right I walk home with Sarah once
more gotta save one more time even
though it's only been a few days a lot
of things have already changed but today
C or E is being a little quieter than
usual on the way home hey C or E yeah
sorry
how's spacing out ah no wonder I was
thinking about something from earlier I
liked how we get to I mean Sarah fumbles
with the words so let's just say that
one day Natsuki asked to walk home with
you huh
what would you do what kind of question
is that you're kind of putting me on the
spot here
decision decision huh well I mean it's
if she has to walk home is it out of my
way I mean we're conveniently living
near each other so but you know you know
dope yeah I probably don't walk back
with you I guess yeah yeah sure okay say
Yuri you really think I would ditch you
for the Mitsuki yeah but but she's so
cute and fun to be around
geez I already see her in the club every
day besides you always seem to really
like going home together I wouldn't just
ruin that for you it's so silly more
Marv you so Shelly you think about me
too much sometimes you're so jelly now
Sookie would deserve it if she wanted it
so sorry I've already made up my mind
once and forever this decision here is
final two takes stake president over
everything I mean honestly I don't like
bings I don't like being narrowed down
into the people I can walk home with but
you know it is if Yuri
now if Yuri that's a different story
Monica Monica uh
drop you like a hat I really can't
figure you out sometimes sorry
besides what's the point of speculating
something that's never gonna happen huh
the conversation trails off kind of a
weird thing for say already care so much
about but I wanted to respect her and
keep her happy too
then again the festival is only a few
days away who knows what will happen in
that time yeah death will happen
probably probably oh god I have to write
another one I have no idea how this
one's gonna go yeah boy all right hang
on
Oh
[Music]
okay that's right wearable everyone
hates me now okay so I'm gonna try to
write a red one for URI accidentally and
I've written one for Natsuki I'm gonna
try to write one for for say your II
hope ah there we go
y ou go boom boom bum bum bum bum shame
cool cool cool I'll do god there's a
poof can't step poof buh buh buh
okay there we go buh buh buh buh duh buh
duh buh buh buh I jump beat up nope
that's not what I want okay here we go
where's the family there we are
we got the family and doop boop boo boo
doo doo boo the loop-de-loop the email
ah
okay not doing good joy yeah there's
some joy it's oh no no Bob a little bit
of fun baby Duke come do the lip but
fear bump beep bop boop boop boop hair
pump whoops then dude that tears there
we go how about du Loup boot up party up
B look but but hurt up but bit look
that's do get okey-dokey baby do
but play a little up but boxer library
there but uh nature love it up a new
boat together love a double-dip boat
nest me I
that's my Babbitt childhood hey I think
I got it you can think I got a
predominantly good one oh man what what
is it I'm the last one here again don't
worry I just walked into were you
practicing piano again
yeah ha ha ha you must have a lot of
determination
no one's anything sorry this club I'd
miss it well and maybe not determination
but I guess passion remember that the
club wouldn't be here if it wasn't all
for you and I'm super happy that you're
all willing to help out for the festival
- I can't wait for the festival oh it's
gonna be great all right
weren't you complaining about it just
yesterday Natsuki well yeah I'm not
talking about our part in the festival
but it's a whole day of school where we
get to play and even all kinds of
delicious food you sound a bit like say
Orry all of a sudden Monica did they
usually have fried squid squid that's a
pretty specific thing to look forward to
oh come on are you saying you don't like
squid no miss squid lover huh I am
handling squid lover 99 we all know that
I didn't say I don't like it besides
what do you mean by you of all people
because writing your name Monica yeah
that's how you say my name at all also
that joke makes no sense in translation
I never mind let's just focus on your
own event for now okay fine fine fine
your reactions aren't as fun as URIs or
say or YZ anyway excuse me where is C or
E anyway oh there you are
say Orion that is at the desk in the
corner the room looking down at nothing
why walk over to her hey say Ari I waved
my hand in front of her face yeah you're
spacing out again ah sorry don't mind me
you can go talk to everyone else huh
is everything all right of course why
wouldn't it be
it feels like you're a bit off sorry for
assuming things tease you worry too much
about me I'm fine see shows me a big
smile
don't let me distract you from having
fun with everyone okay all right if you
say so
i weirdly glance at say Ari before
turning back towards everyone else but
the conversation is already dispersed
and everyone back at their usual
activities maybe I should ask Monica if
she's noticing anything about C or E
recently since they've been preparing
for the festival they must be spending a
lot of time together i timidly
approached Monica who's shuffling from
papers throughout her desk more what's
up hey this might sound a little strange
but uh have you know same things up with
C or E recently
anything up with her and what weight do
you mean maybe I'm reading into it a
little too much but she seems a bit
downcast today oh you think so
can't say I've noticed anything about
her Monica peers across around the C or
E who's idly dragging a rubber eraser up
and down her desk maybe there is
something on her mind but I'm surprised
I'm not the one asking you morp you
certainly know her a lot better than I
do
yeah but she's never really like this
she's always talked to me about things
that bothered her but this time when I
asked her she was really dismissive
sorry I know it's not your problem I
just wanted to ask if you knew anything
so I'll drop it now no no no no it's
important to me too I mean I'm also
friends with her and I also care about
the well-being of my club members you
know maybe I'll try talking to her
myself with my robot emotions that
always works out for everybody why not
yeah you sure about that she seemed like
she wanted to be left alone are you sure
maybe she just has a hard time bringing
out up with the person of interest
oh person of interest what do you mean
by that I'm saying that maybe the thing
on her mind is you more me you come to
that conclusion why the handsome guy
like me with amazing social skills and
lifelong childhood friend oh I probably
shouldn't say too much but Sarah talks
about you more than anything else you
know yeah she's been so much happier
ever since you joined the club it's like
an extra light was turned on inside of
her always like that she's always been
full of sunshine it's not any different
now than it always has been
yeah you're so funny more have you
thought that maybe you've always seen
her so cheerful because that's just how
she is when she's around you I said too
much I'm sorry
what do I know anyway I didn't mean to
jump to conclusions you should prolly
just forget about what I said I'll tried
to talk to her so try not to think about
it for now
ah all right Monica smiles meaningfully
I know she said to forget about it but I
already know that I won't be able to get
her words out of my handy Monica stands
up from her desk and walks across the
room to where she or he is sitting i
watch her kneel down next to Sarah and
generally talk to her but she's keeping
her voice so quiet that I can't hear
from here I sigh and sit myself down oh
the burdens of having all the
ladies after you oh wow a curse it is to
be as handsome as me I know Sarah Tommy
enough to worry about her been to have
fun with everyone else that's impossible
to do when she's behaving like this
exactly how much I do care I care for
her
do I do I care that I'm letting this
weigh me down so much now I'm feeling
like I'm the one behaving out of the
ordinary but there's nothing I can do
besides wait for Monica Hey oh sorry
excuse me sorry well I look up to see
Natsuki next to me are you just gonna
sit there and stare nothing there's no
much time so I'm sorry I didn't mean to
make you worry or anything so I've been
worried about you I was just now Sookie
glances down at her side she's holding a
volume of manga in her hand that's right
something just came up for a minute but
we can get started now I won't make you
wait any longer
jeez now you're making me feel like a
jerk something's bothering you then you
just tell me to leave you alone and I
will I mean assuming that you didn't
feel like talking about or anything she
practically mumbles the last part no I'm
probably making it seem like a bigger
deal than it is
I've just been thinking about say Orie
that's all so you're thinking about whoa
yeah she seems pretty down today but she
didn't want to admit it to me so I can't
help but wonder if something's Avenue
her oh well first of all you should
really work on your phrasing but anyway
you're her best friend right yeah I
guess so
yeah then in that case I think you
should trust her a little more if she
needed you then you'd be the first
person she would go to right well I
guess that's true I mean some people
just have those days you can't always
avoid it if anything she probably just
doesn't want you to worry about her
because it's not important yeah that
kind of was what she said to me maybe
it's not right for me to go against her
wishes
exactly so shut up and read this manga
with me
she needs you worry about her then it'll
be a lot more obvious yeah I should have
thought of it that way from the start
Natsuki fiddles with the book she's
holding her hand she she really means a
lot to You doesn't she
ah oh what no nothing no like garbage
they threw out on any day don't get the
wrong idea or anything we've just been
friends for a long time it's normal to
be worried about your friend I mean you
were worried about me so I was not and
we're not friends so screw you and go to
hell
geez if you're fine well let's hurry and
get started already yeah yeah all right
whoo wait what's goin on oh okay
everyone after some time passes Monica
calls out from the club room why don't
we share our palms now before I know
what everything's back to normal
okay before we move on I'm gonna end
this one here and it is interesting I
feel like it's about to take a turn at
any moment here III don't know why I
expected just like blood to shoot out of
the windows right away in this game but
I have a feeling it's getting to that
point where the truth is being revealed
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
the comments below and write your poems
down there as well and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]